hey it's Stephanie Wong and welcome to
season of skill a new series I created
to help you build scale and resilience
into your design patterns today I'll be
covering the basics behind how to do
that stay tuned with everything going on
in the world there's been undeniable
disruption for businesses social
isolation around the globe has settled
in and traditional brick-and-mortar
companies have been forced to shift
operations into an online space while
already online companies are seeing a
massive spike in daily traffic this
might have put a lot of pressure on you
to adapt and evolve your online
architectures and maybe face realization
that you're both resource and business
constraint this rang true for critter
Junction a multiplayer gaming company
that's gained massive popularity in the
last few months online players can
interact with one another in a virtual
world that follows life simulation as a
critter building and operating a gaming
stack at this scale requires a lot of
careful planning so my team and I are
stepping in to help critter Junction
revisit their design practices for
ultimate global success so far critter
Junction has been great at running into
visual machines on premise but hasn't
really been able to automatically scale
too many machines to handle peaks and
dips in traffic at times they end up
running over utilized machines and other
times run underutilized machines and
having built resilience into their
architecture a failure in networking
image updates or peak load could lead to
a disruption in their game players
experience on top of that critter
Junction has its own business and
operational pressures their CTO is all
about becoming more agile to adapt to
fluctuating user demands their
developers are focusing on reducing the
time it takes to investigate failures
and their operators care about finding
ways to automatically recover from
failures this is a lot to think about
but let's start by first explaining what
scalability and resilience are
scalability is the measure of a system's
ability to handle varying amounts of
work by adding or removing resources
from the system for example a scalable
web app can not only work well with one
user but also with 100 million users and
it can gracefully handle
Keeks and dips in traffic the good news
is the cloud gives you the flexibility
to adjust the resources consumed by an
app the bad news without proper design
you could end up using more resources
than you need
like what critter junctions done
on-premise what you want instead is to
reduce costs by removing underutilized
resources without compromising
performance or user experience that
being said even scalable apps can face
disruptions without resilience built-in
system failures can throw a wrench in
your operations resilience means
designing to withstand failures a
resilient app is one that continues to
function
despite failures of system components
and this requires planning at all levels
of your architecture it influences how
you layout your infrastructure and
network and how you design your data
storage and app it even extends to
people and culture let's face it
building and operating resilient apps is
hard especially for distributed gaming
stacks which means multiple layers of
infrastructure networks and services so
over this season we're going to walk
critter Junction through Google cloud
design best practices to help them build
both scalable and resilient apps all in
all these patterns and best practices
will fall into three themes automation
because automating your infrastructure
provisioning testing and app deployments
increases consistency and speed and
minimizes human error loose coupling
because treating your system as a
collection of loosely coupled
independent components gives you
flexibility and resilience and
data-driven design because collecting
metrics to your app is critical
decisions about when to scale your app
or when a particular service is
unhealthy needs to be based on data
these themes are going to be crucial to
laying a stronger foundation to scale
and withstand failures mistakes and
outages happen but critter Junction is
on a mission to improve the design of
their app architecture and dev processes
stay tuned to find out how and remember
always be architecting
[Music]